[موسيقى]
في الثالث من فبراير 2020 رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يلتقي في
اوغندا رئيس المجلس السيادي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان ومكتب نتنياهو يقول
انهما اتفقا على بدء الحوار من اجل تطبيع
العلاقات بين الطرفين في الخامس من الشهر
نفسه قال نتنياهو ان الخرطوم اعطت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه موافقه مبدئيه على
الطيران في الاجواء السودانيه في الثالث
والعشرين من اكتوبر 2020 وفي خضم الاعلان
عما سميت باتفاقيات ابراهم اعلن كل من
السودان واسرائيل انهم اتفقا بوساطه
امريكيه على تطبيع العلاقات بينهما وتزامن
ذلك مع تصريح لرئيس الامريكي انذاك دونالد
ترامب عزمه ازاله اسم السودان من قوائم
الارهاب في الخامس والعشرين من يناير 2021
وفي زياره هي الاولى من نوعها وزير
المخابرات الاسرائيلي انذاك يصل الخرطوم
على راسه وفن رسمي ويلتقي وزير الدفاع
السوداني ياسين ابراهيم في الثاني عشر من
فبراير 2022
رئيسه مجلس السياده الانتقالي عبد الفتاح
البرهان يقول ان التعاون الامني
لاستخباراتي بين السودان واسرائيل لم
يتوقف منذ لقائهم مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قبل عامين في
الاول من ابريل 2022 قالت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ان وفد امنيا اسرائيليا عاليا
المستوى انها زياره رسميه الى السودان وان
مباحثاته هناك اقتصرت على الجوانب الامنيه
دون القضايا السياسيه في الثاني من فبراير
مجلس سياده السوداني يكشف عن لقاء جرى بين
رئيسه عبد الفتاح البرهان ووزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي في الخرطوم ويقول ان اللقاء
بين البرهان وكوهين تطرق الى تعزيز
العلاقات بين الطرفين وافاق التعاون
الاقتصادي والزراعي والعسكري